how you doing there reject nation I'm
Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey we're doing
a video podcast yeah no one does podcast
we're the first ones ever to do it
what's a podcast well John it's where we
just talk
don't edit ourselves we're uncensored
unfiltered act like we're just hanging
out and talking but really we're still
recording and filming a video so one of
our top reward tiers at our patreon page
is whatever video you request and must
do and put up on YouTube and a few of
our top reward tier patrons have been
requesting video podcasts which I'm very
much grateful for I like doing these
this one is gonna be a little bit more
structured only because we got quite a
bit of people to quickly run through but
this comes from Andrew Hayes and he has
a wonderful YouTube channel by the way
you guys should go check that out as
soon as you can he's been on the real
rejects I cover his movie reviews
sometimes talks about wrestling and
movie and TV shows and stuff anyway his
reward to request is best directorial
debuts and you know it's like we could
have just taken what he requested and
made it like a top 10 list but why do
that it's a video podcast we're just
gonna go through so many directors and
any random order that we wish to just
name off some good ones some great ones
in fact yeah and also you know I'm sure
there's gonna be directors that we do
not mention that you're gonna be like
why didn't you mention this you forgot
sort of getting pissed at us you can do
just put it in the comment boxes
engagement so yeah I mean I I feel like
there's there's so many here I'm just
gonna kick it off I knew this is gonna
I'm gonna start with the most cliche one
and you know what John since we have so
many I'm gonna cross them off as we as
we go so we don't have to keep searching
picture the initial lid off to the races
my first one that I would probably want
to mention is Quentin Tarantino it's
like trust me there's more not so cliche
answers that we have coming your way but
Tarantino with Reservoir Dogs he I think
Soderbergh is someone who's on this list
but Soderbergh really kicked off a lot
of the independent filmmaking era that
we got in the nineties even though Sex
Lies and videotape was an 89 what
Tarantino did with Reservoir Dogs kind
of catapulted everything I feel like
Reservoir Dogs is the most important
directorial debut perhaps of our
generation yes and I think out of the
independent filmmaking generation as
well because in the 80s where they
weren't as experimental or as willing to
try out new things Reservoir Dogs sort
of pushed it onto the map in a way where
it was a weird structure it was
different and yet he got very fortunate
that he was able to hit such a pretty
big cast amazing cast yeah yeah and it's
like him directing it he hadn't hand
directed anything else before and you
know like he I was actually hearing
interview with him recent there's this
wonderful interview kawatche that was I
it was from the El Rey Network Rob
Rodriguez's channel network director
back and forth yeah and it is a two-part
a YouTube cut you could watch its total
it comes that's like 90 minutes or
something like that and Rodriguez was
going into all this like history of how
he became the first like rock and roll
pop culture sort of director because
everywhere he went he was like swarmed
by fans and everything I mean that well
really solidified that was this follow
up with pulp fiction but Reservoir Dogs
I feel is even if it's not your favorite
Tarantino film proven one of your
favorites from the 90s there's no doubt
it is one of the most important films if
we're talking about the 90s so yeah I
was a Tarantino with what he and he just
he's been very consistent since yeah and
really growing
yeah trying to trying to yes and you oh
who would you mention here um like oddly
enough I figured if we do one from
various
let's go back a little ways and this is
when we just watched recently and it's
been fresh in my mind and when I was you
know kind of thinking about and looking
up directorial debuts and I found this
one I was kind of shocked that John
Huston's first movie was The Maltese
Falcon because that movie does hold up
pretty well I mean we both just watched
it recently it's a pretty great mystery
and it's a pretty iconic film noir and
that's like the defining film they wore
yeah and it's one that took you know out
of the pulp novels detective novels and
stuff and really gave us our first
truest iteration of that style on screen
right of the way for a whole genre and
and one that has warped and persisted
and grown over time you know and yeah
it's that's a movie that even to this
day you know is still pretty compelling
like I said in that podcast we we
watched that in film school or not even
film school high school and it was one
of the few classics that even the high
school kids was like pretty good well
yeah I mean yeah this is something we
touched on was how you know like classic
films of that error or not exactly my
co2 catalog to search for all my
wouldn't you film but I'll have what
film have I not seen that I want check
out but watching that movie was a
surprisingly very easy watch and felt a
lot of modern in the cinematography so
you guys haven't seen that it's a great
film yes sir I'm gonna go very recent
here
arias sir Oh read it Terry it's a great
call that movie blue like that one thing
you'll you'll hear a lot with a lot of
these directors with their directorial
debuts is you know there's like people
on here you know I mean the rather than
make it a listener I just keep talking
about people like Rob Rodriguez his
debut was with El Mariachi which is very
rough around the edges and had this sort
of b-movie grindhouse esque sort of
quality to it which brought a lot of its
charm and that came out the same year as
Reservoir Dogs and from my understanding
because I heard that interview recently
it seemed like Tarantino and Rodriguez
were actually friends even before that I
I thought that was what made them
friends yes both of these huge
independent hits but they sort of were
collaborative already or like we're in
class together something like that if I
forget I could be wrong about that
donating plasma together
basically right now we're in the middle
of a move and was you know doing like I
had it playing in the background while I
was packing a bunch of stuff said I
think that's what I picked up on either
way their their films their first film's
debut together that year and something
like Rob Rodriguez where I mean it's
pretty even as charming and even though
out of the el Mariachi trilogy a lot of
people still say that is the best one
there's a reason why he went and redid
it again with desperado because he felt
he could have done it better and had a
better confident hand with his direction
and editing with it even though it's
still the restaurant was not the
preferred one generally speaking el Mar
do actually had that flavor whereas a
lot of these directors seem like they've
had so many years of experience and re
austere demonstrated that with
hereditary this sure fine confident hand
with his direction where you're like
what else is good this is the first film
what the hell yeah [ __ ] no strike yeah
just film like and it's one of those
like somebody else who I'm sure will
mention pretty soon this might actually
be a great segue to Jordan Peele forget
out because both of those guys with
hereditary and get out you watch both
those movies and you're like man this is
your first feature but like it looks
like you sculpted every inch of this yes
and that's part of what makes hereditary
so damn impressive too is because even
if you don't love where the story goes
all the time it is just so
quintessentially itself you know yeah
well I think what Jordan Peele would
would get out he's other than of course
all the amount of studying he's done I
think with the amount of genre blending
that took place on key and Peele even
though everything had to be funny there
was a lot of genre blending he had a lot
of experience that he brought to there
and I think what he did would get out
was it's very impressive to when it's a
lot of these directors I think it's not
just their first film they directed but
also the first feature they wrote yeah
probably the one they spent the most
time you know yes and that's like a real
baby of theirs and get out I heard he
spent like six years working on that
film or something like that
had the script at least four six
whenever you hear people say that you
just imagine like that's all they worked
on for six years then every day it's
really not the case a lot of it is
I took a break from it for like a few
months and then I went back and revisit
it yeah over there exactly even let it
it sort of grow for people oh if they
get this impression that just slaved
away like that we actually went down but
yeah Jordan Peele would get out is
something that I feel like you have to
mention on this little for the for the
wave yeah it's sort of brought in it
it's like you know something made an
impact when other films in the genre
suddenly just immediately get compared
to it yeah yeah and make you a household
name like right off the bat yeah and
speaking a horror this director what's
funny about this guy he's a [ __ ] no no
don't speak ill of the dead George
Romero Night of the Living Dead I don't
think John you I was at the point that
joke George Romero in Night of the
Living Dead that's not my favorite and
his franchise I Donna the dead is my
favorite one and you know what I think
land of the dead is pretty amazing cuz I
had a backwards experience with the of
the Dead franchise I watched land of the
dead first and the theaters so I was
just curious to check it out and I'm
watching it twice as I loved it so much
and then I went backwards and I watched
on to the dead then Dan to dead the
Night of the Living Dead it was a real
like we're done chronological or but the
thing with every last one in black so
but Night of the Living Dead is the film
that's been remade like a couple of
times now it's a defining zombie genre
it's like that is the that is the genre
yeah set so many of the genre like you
know in a similar way I would imagine -
how you know Maltese Falcon set those
cinematic earmarks for film Noirs so did
this for the zombie horror movie because
you know like the zombies as we know
them now come out of that movie
basically yeah well the thing with film
noir is a genre that I you don't really
hear movies come out today that are
pitched as a film noir it's like you'll
find out oh this
has qualities of a film noir you'll have
you hear the word noir graduated on the
back of other you'll hear like critics
say that you'll hear like Oh brick comes
out Ryan Johnson's movie yeah yeah so
brick comes out people say oh film you
are but you know it's not being pitched
as a film noir and so like Maltese
Falcon black-and-white that era you know
you would hear that as a genre but
something with Night of the Living Dead
I feel like that's a genre that's really
evolved and has changed like I wouldn't
say not a living dead is some some might
argue it is because it's a staple it's
the first one it's the best zombie movie
but I it's really not even like in my
top five I really love that to me
personally you know is with you there's
something about it that has like I love
Dawn of the Dead - and I got a really
like it's been a long time since I've
seen a lot of the other sequels I have
the most familiarity with those two but
not a living dead really does kind of
stick up there in my mind is one of my
favorite horror movies and maybe it's
because that it is a little bit less
kind I don't know there's something with
the black and white charm and the
isolation of everything and just sort of
the aesthetic of that movie that I just
really do love from a genuine place so
um well to me it's sort of feels like
what Rodriguez had with al mariachis you
know where it's like not much of a
budget you got a lot to do a lot of
things to work around here a lot of
compromises you got to making and would
and with those limitations you made
something great yeah and so it does have
that that level of charm to it where you
Rian Johnson a brick research i I saw a
movie in the theaters with my dad and
you know whenever that came out when I
was probably pretty young yeah I don't
know did jgl Georgia Joseph
gordon-levitt
okay so jingle says I don't know what
Joseph gordon-levitt's career in terms
of acting was like but I really think in
that movie specific
we put him on the map or at least in the
eyes of man that kid from third Rock
from the Sun no I think that movie
really did a lot to catapult him into an
adult star you know yeah child acting
cuz you know it didn't do the same thing
for Lukas Haas but that's you know an
awesome example of something that is
really in the film noir tradition but is
also very much in the neo noir tradition
as well it's very modern it takes its
own versions of the slang and of
specific imagery and the types of
situations but it plays them in its own
quirky way and so yeah it's it's I feel
like that's a great example of a true
neo noir because it does so many of
these stylistic earmarks but it really
translates them to the now absolutely
yeah that was a great one that's a great
one Coates and David Lynch I feel for
some reason just looking over the list
I'm like it feels like a good transition
yeah gotta get surreal yeah David Lynch
with Eraserhead
he came onto the scene with that at a
really interesting time because like I
said the 80s I remember actually in that
interview Tarantino was it was saying
that the 80s were like a various sort of
oppressive time even in filmmaking that
they were really daring and I believe I
don't raise her head came out like late
70s pretty much 76 mid to summer there
[Music]
so Eraserhead came out then and which
seems kind of more appropriate for the
70s but in the so he was right at the
time when filmmaking wasn't a was about
did not become as crazy yeah it's like
on the cusp you're probably seeing yeah
the transitions out of the you know
really protracted naturalistic stuff
into kind of a maybe a midway ground
between yeah where it's kind of weird
and crazy but it's also grounded and
there's a lot of space you know erases I
feel you can probably comment on
Eraserhead better than I can
I can't because I haven't seen
Eraserhead oh wow you haven't seen
Eraserhead
know it's I'm working my
'we higgledy-piggledy through david lee
one of those movies i shouldn't have
watched when i was a kid and i barely
remember it but i remember being very
disturbing yep I really want you like
bottom well even if we haven't seen a
racer head or like or haven't seen it
recently you know it should be on this
list like I am ashamed because that is a
movie I really do want to see and that's
a like a defining body horror movie yeah
yeah yeah and I fantasize about doing
little units for myself of like going
back and reviewing certain directors
filmography and David Lynch is
definitely one I want to do that with so
yeah when we follow from this podcast
I'll have things to say and I also think
another like here's how we've been doing
this we've just been transitioning
around not going in order and I think a
transition from that a good one would
have to be Bradley Cooper with the Stars
cue that intro from a star is born
is that directorial debut where I could
feel an intimate passion for like a lot
of heart for what he's working on there
you know a lot of times would it's like
you get a wide variety of direct order
because some people really go for the
heavy some people really go for sort of
something it's like weird and different
something you haven't seen before and a
star is born that was my favorite movie
of last year it wasn't you know
something that we necessarily haven't
seen before though you know I'd say that
but we've seen it four times I got the
fourth remake third remake fourth one of
the stars weren't factoring that and
either way it was an interesting debut
for because like I said it's the thing
that stood out to me was the heart and
love for what he was crafting there as
opposed to trying to do something
completely original and completely
different it was the communication of
emotions that I really yeah yeah just so
kind of had it's hard on its sleeve it
was so kind of emotionally forward never
actor turned director that makes a lot
of sense yeah yeah let's keep everything
really fluid closed up and very intimate
and and this is actually a nice segue I
think to talking about another actor got
a review after turn director yeah so
this is just do it again
yeah but one film that really impressed
me from a first-time director a longtime
actor first-time caller longtime fan is
joel edgerton is the gift yeah because
that movie is kind of on the opposite
side of the spectrum in the sense that
it is very potent emotionally but it is
also very deliberate and very almost
like Hitchcockian and it's you know
tension and release and use of suspense
and stuff like that you know it has a
certain clinical reserved miss it while
also again being very effective yeah
yeah yeah and very harrowing in a lot of
ways well a lot of times with the actors
turned directors especially depending on
the genre they've come from a session
like in the acting field I think Jordan
Peele is a was a surprise for a lot of
people because he came from key & peele
which was a very dope comedy yeah and
then get outs like wow yeah whereas the
gift
knowing joel edgerton acting chops and
like the genres he's worked in like to
see him transition to that what it
wasn't a surprise it's more of what he
was embarking on and I think it was
smart for him not to be the lead yeah in
it but as and and kind of nice for him
to play a character that gets kind of
unlikable at times pretty damn unlikable
it's yeah yeah yeah but it was the kind
of role to that I think was when you're
working as a actor turned director when
you're doing that approach yeah it's the
kind of role where you have to really
feed a lot to the other actors work off
of something when they're the main ones
you need the response up for Rebecca
Hall Rebecca Howe Rebecca Hall and Jason
Bateman yeah well that's very smart then
because you know he's given them the
directions and he's also motivating most
like that's yeah that's pretty great you
know Gibson
I think yeah the man without a face is
that face man without a face Mel Gibson
I would say as well as another a lot of
people kind of forget about that that
was his directorial debut so I don't
know if it's like worth mentioning on
this list I'll allow it
yeah you allow it honestly I kind of
really remember that
movie but I love now Braveheart wasn't
his first movie I'm just gonna say real
quick right there because there's some
shadow of doubt over this but Sam Raimi
Evil Dead Sam Raimi is that is his first
movie yeah the thing is he made
something that borders on feature-length
like five years or like seven years
before or something like that
called it's murder the thing is I don't
know really where you can find it and if
it counts so I think you know at least
with an asterisk by its name the Evil
Dead is you know right those films which
is not necessarily the best of its
franchise either but is responsible for
a certain amount I would think of the
80s you know blow budget horror wave and
stuff like that and has certainly been a
bigger influence on us now Evil Dead is
that's it's funny with a lot of these
horror directors cuz you duque actually
I'm night Shyamalan people think six
cents
it's like unbreakable a second film six
seven like no that's not the case he
directs a movie like how Rosie O'Donnell
and I think weird comedy that he made
one he also made a movie that he started
like his very first film I think was
just like about him was like yeah like
it down to earth like character story or
yeah character drama I think a lot of
people tend to get confused as if like
the first movie that made them like
famous as a director they think is their
first movie when I'm like no that's
that's not your slave you and John
Krasinski on this list but I believe he
did direct something before that though
right
we're doubled this is we're researching
or we Colin are we searching while were
are we doing like if he directed TV it
doesn't count or if it's like feature
film debut no I think no yeah he's
directed a movie right here it says of
the hollers an hour and 28 minute movie
no yeah that's what I mean get out of
here Kristen Squire place was his first
film wasn't the case yeah also another
writer actor turned director Ben Affleck
for Gone Baby Gone where he put his
brother in there the
Alex man got a great reputation in a
game yeah they're always won sexually
abuses the others an alcoholic become a
rageful alcoholic he seems like a
depressive alcohol actually making fun
of real people because they're famous
that we feel we have a right
they don't come across as human or just
characters from characters we see on the
media outlet but Gone Baby Gone that's
not my favorite of the ones he's uh he's
directed I love the town the most but
Gone Baby Gone I thought was a really I
thought was interesting and how he
approached making the movie because it's
not doesn't it's like been athletes
names the director and I think I think
he's a co-writer on it and then he puts
the Affleck name with his brother who's
nowhere near same time like more people
know the Casey Affleck name now but at
the time Casey Affleck was mainly known
as Ben Affleck brother you know you know
and you still know the Affleck name you
like you have to route casey through Ben
yeah but that was that was a I feel like
what he demonstrated there it got even
more fine-tuned with things like Argo
and the town the town that the one
that's my favorite yeah the Argo and the
town were Gone Baby Gone was it was a
interesting dramatic is dramatic
thriller kidnapping movie solving the
case they're watching whatever
corruption is unfolding in the Boston PD
in something like that and that right
like the dealing with what he did there
I thought he did a little bit better in
the town but Gone Baby Gone had were the
the thrills of the town and Argo are
present Gone Baby Gone really kind of
doubles out on the dramatic side and
less on the thrill side at least for my
personal viewing experience maybe I
shouldn't have watched the town first
because it got me a gig honor I've
always register more is like
a heavy drama that's how it came across
whereas the other films these that have
more thrills in them you know a little
more exploitable elements but let's mix
it up choose someone different John I am
going to choose Orson Welles arguably
perhaps the greatest directorial yeah
only because like he just did [ __ ]
everything on that movies like he wrote
it I think he directed it he stars in it
he like is the only film yet complete
control over I mean he was War of the
Worlds was something he was like known
for there was the radio show at the time
right and he fought for just like you've
kind of he's pretty OCD got all he
wanted all the control he wanted all the
control it wasn't like no one was
helping him he keep fought to keep all
the controls in pre-production
post-production say over Final Cut yeah
everything he had complete control over
so yeah in a lot of ways even though he
was a like a controlling dude it is the
greatest directorial debut are you
believe because especially when knowing
how it's like the film student thing to
say Citizen Kane well and to be fair I
mean like I've seen it a couple times
and I think it's a compelling movie it's
not my favorite movie by any stretch of
the imagination but I see what's to be a
pretty remarkable achievement yeah and
and and it is like just even though
there are other people involved I'm
still just like I'm sure that he
micromanaged you though yeah definitely
definitely certainly seems like that is
yeah just a through-and-through
it's just Orson Welles that movie is him
you know and also what I like to call
the three Steve's
who one intentionally just got stacked
together a by process of deleting names
off this list Steven Soderbergh Steve
McQueen and Steven Spielberg who spill
Rick's kind of in that weird ground cuz
doulas is like the most well known TV
movie ever and it's kind of crazy and
out there and it's got a very like high
concept about it i cuz he did duel and
then his first movie to the big screen
it started Goldie Hawn I can't remember
like I I remember the plot better than I
do
Sugarland Express I think is what it's
called okay like didn't II did jaws but
Dule that's a TV movie hmm and it's kind
of weirded you it's it wasn't the
feature for the guy who talks against
Netflix it's kind of funny your kickoff
maybe that's why though maybe he's like
I couldn't get nominated for an Academy
Award for deal I think what has helped
duels of claim to fame sort of rise is
the fact that it's kind of got in the
jaws comparison because jaws was the
defining block the start of the
blockbuster movies and the people will
go well if you saw his work in duel yeah
you know what and I think because of
that comparison and try to find out
where did this [ __ ] art for Jaws come
from when you go - and I think that the
talk of duel sort of allowed dual to
become more famous yeah you know hosted
kick-started the killer truck genre
supernatural so spill brew there
Soderbergh like I said because that was
89 Sex Lies and videotape but you know
it was a very Soderbergh I it's great
I'm mixing it up but like that was
another one with like sure like
unbelievable confident direction for a
first-time debut he I think he wrote the
film as well and I don't really remember
the movie gonna say is it one of the
ones where I know he is as a directors
really into doing kind of unorthodox
things or trying out new tech or well
there was an edgy it's called Sex Lies
and videotape and it's a very adult
movie and very edgy film but it's it's a
damn good one I remember that it's a
damn good one but like I said there's
soda break in 89 and Tarantino in 92 we
were two really catapulted it but I
really think sort of break it deserves a
lot of credit for sort of starting off
that independent filmmaking era yeah and
and and continuing to cultivate it over
time and and really sticking - I mean to
Tarantino and Soderbergh have stuck to
their guns in a lot of their own ways
but for real like you know Soderbergh
will oscillate back and forth between
like oh that's in a movie theater you
know like
megaplex and then it'll be like
something that plays on five screens
that was like shot on an iPhone with
like only yeah you know people who
aren't actors and stuff and I like that
he still bounces around you know those
different things and of course the last
Steve Steve McQueen with hunger was the
prison movie
yeah the prison one based on a true
story which kick-started I think human
Ryan Coogler kind of similar thing where
and Riker is on this list
yeah for Fruitvale station both these
directors found that our go-to actor
yeah
where and what I find funny is Steve
McQueen does hunger with Michael
Fassbender right right cougar does
Fruitvale station on Michael B Jordan
the next film I think Steve McQueen's
exchanging with Michael Fassbender Yeah
right
Aaron googlers was was it Creed yeah
yeah yeah it was Creed and and then
their third film their go-to actor was
the villain Steve McQueen puts Michael
FAAST mentor as there's a lot of
villains and he is the main antagonist
yeah
out of them all in the move like out of
all the antagonists you will remember it
is definitely Michael Fassbender in that
movie and then of course Michael B
Jordan is kill monger and Black Panther
the steep like but with hunger Steve
McQueen made a very that was another one
with leisure like confident hand behind
the camera for directorial debut and
that right there like edit
koogler has managed to really go into
mainstream oh yeah you know Steve
McQueen's kicked off with something very
not for everyone very edgy uncomfortable
to sit through and Kugler you know I
have more that independent touch with
Fruitvale station but failed station is
a very warm movie and a lot of ways in a
very it's not like wrenching until it
gets wrench yeah where but with hunger
like that is a difficult film to sit
through
it's a great film to sit through they
know I haven't seen shame though Oh
get ready for the flick Michael
Fassbender because because when he tried
going a little more mainstream Steve
McQueen with yeah and with widows which
I liked it was did it really fully
appeal to every way you know I got
imagine that even if he was to make a
mainstream blockbuster it would still be
very filmy yes still be very fleshed out
and very you know like thick because he
sort of stayed in that direction with
uncomfortable pushing the boundaries raw
realism Steve McQueen's filmmaking style
res Ryan Coogler can really adjust to
the genre he's working in yeah yeah and
the Fruitvale station something you
could probably speak a little more on
because you saw recently yeah yeah yeah
oh right I saw all the Ryan Coogler
joints in reverse order so I saw you
know black panther then I saw Creed and
then I saw Fruitvale and Fruitvale was
just one that I put on cuz I was just
compelled one day I was flipping through
movies and and yeah like that is such a
lively it just really took me by
surprise because it is very of its time
in place but it's also very lively and
very alive like I was expecting
something to be very heavy whereas most
of the movie you're just peering into
this guy's life and really learning to
sympathize and empathize and and love
this guy and then yeah I just spent the
whole last 20 minutes just crying ugly
cry I got a yeah yeah cuz like it is
really it's a really effecting moving
for sure I'm looking at one more
director while we go through is like a
lot of these directors sort of popping
into my head that's what they don't know
okay
good thing we did not put him on here so
I guess such you know we've definitely
female directors know we might as well
talk about a couple yeah Jennifer Kent
for the babadook I adore that movie yes
that is one of my favorite I've only
seen him one time and it quickly made
the list not five favorite horror movies
you know I actually have the pop-up
books I oh you do yeah it's become quite
a big collectible
yeah the babadook is this psychological
horror that's one of those the hugely
miss advertised
get ready for in-your-face monster yeah
it's not that at all a night and I
barely room I didn't I've been seen the
trailer maybe one time and then years
later i watch the babadook way but so I
just sort of watch it with a fresh lens
and I I do love that film and I think
that is a beautifully haunting movie
yeah when it has a surprise ending that
you have to sort of read into yeah
that's sort of I think you do have to
read into it to fully grasp like what's
sort of happening there yeah I mean I
get what's kind of divisive for some
people about that movie but to me it's
one that gives you both it gives you a
convincing and compelling and
claustrophobic and oppressive monster
movie but it also gives you yeah the
psychological exploration of this single
mother right and all the anguish that
comes with that and all the just tricky
life things that come with that and yeah
it's another one of those debuts that is
so assured and also is very rich in its
like film history in a sense because
there's so much that borrows from old
silent movies and old ex German
Expressionism and things like that and
so yeah you know you you watch it and
you're like wow this feels like it would
have been your third or fourth film
right right yeah and some other female
directors are popping my mind I just
want to confirm that I am correct about
this okay not Kathryn Bigelow's and say
near dark but I haven't seen her first
film so I can't comment on which our
first film so at patty Jenkins was her
first movie monster I feels like she's
got a pretty limited filmography I
understand she's only directed to movies
that's always been it's necessary for
teen movies for teen right here yeah her
first movie was monster patty hands not
bad I was trying to think it's gotta be
other female directors I just have a
thought but patty Jenkins the monster
that was an indie film that was talked
about and I feel like you will have
heard of that movie even if ya weren't
into films like you know there's a lot
of indie films that come out of people
like never heard of it but monster was
one of them I think Charlize Theron his
performance was a big reason why a lot
of people had heard of that movie but
the way she was able to it's pretty
crazy how she could sort of just hop
from Monster into Wonder Woman which are
two very different films oh yeah but
still have this level of understanding
the humanity behind this very famous
serial killer at the same time not
creating a sympathetic case for her just
a very human tale which was pretty
impressive no I haven't I've seen bits
and pieces it's a very very raw film and
you know what I don't really hear this
work described for it but it's a cool
movie I never hear that word for it but
I thought this is a cool film not every
part of it is cool there's some
disturbing [ __ ] that goes on but it's
pretty cool and it's kind of a weird
word association but yeah pretty cool
foe and this one is a film on I barely
do remember and we're that I discovered
this was her first film before filming
by accident because I was i I was big
I'm a big fan of the movie the
invitation and I was like oh is that the
character seumas first film and it
wasn't it was this movie called it was
Jennifer's janitors potty actually do
she goes back it's crazy
Jennifer's father's got a lot more
respect over the years Karen kusuma did
a movie called girl fight which is the
main reason I remember that movie this
is Michelle Rodriguez his best
performance you'll never see I think you
watch the trailer for it even now you
watch the trailer it looks like just a
generic gonna become a boxer movie but
there was a real level of nuance and
depth that you did not expect that got
brought to life in there and you know
yeah he's good cred for like Michelle
Rodriguez his her just really typecast
as like tough chick in action movies or
something when you know if she just
demonstrated him widows she can really
[ __ ] act and girlfight really should
have been more put her on the map even
more than just that it's like the
trailer just made it look like ah she's
a tough boxer chick but that's not it
like that is a really really damn good
drama I've always gone that's the one of
hers I still need to see
Carn kazama's films but iiii always got
that sense that it had both you know
because you ran we're used to the kind
of blockbuster tough michelle rodriguez
but i got the sense from that movie that
you would get be very human and the
tough yes shouts out to that alright
just got a few more directors to go
through here i another director with
kind of a limited filmography at the
moment but uh one of my favorite movies
in general is district nine and that
would be a Neil Blomkamp's Dave view
it's I mean it wouldn't be fair to put
it on the same level as Citizen Kane but
it's wildly an or Mele for well I'll say
about that is normally wouldn't you get
that kind of movie you will have at
least done something smaller mmm you
know think of everyone who's been
attached to direct the Marvel movie
they've all done something a lot smaller
and then they graduate to this giant
[ __ ] CGI practical like something
crazy right Neil Blomkamp comes onto the
scene with this crazy intimate but big
sci-fi movie and you know that kind of
does yeah it's another one of the films
that does both things cuz it has all
that stuff you want it has the aliens
and the robotics and stuff and it does
the thing is he does have you know a
pretty solid background in making shorts
and doing visual animation and stuff
like that so like his stylistic earmarks
had been at work before that movie but
yeah it is one that has all that cool
[ __ ] but also a very affecting and a
very relevant story about one person
going through a change and also about
oppression in general and and yeah it's
weird to to think about that movie this
is the best film yeah as much as I like
all of his stuff you know I do think it
is his best and the one I could argue
that you need to see the clearest right
and it's funny because talking about the
level you know thinking like oh you know
usually this would be something that
somebody had done something smaller
before this was supposed to be halo it
was supposed to be something bigger and
then you know through whatever series of
events it got to be its own little
original thing and I think that I'm
sorry about that yeah it's a beautiful
happenstance I feel like alright so we
got that one and then
you know just spitballin here Tim Bergen
with pee-wee's big adventure
[Laughter]
hey man people loved it was peewee
before that I see a show wasn't it
pee-wee's Playhouse yeah yeah peewee
peewee come hide your place it's funny
as TVs like Edward Scissorhands is like
the defining Tim Burton origin I think
Allah that is the the top tier of things
people would associate or Beetlejuice
knows beetlejuice then add verses or
hands I feel like beautiful came first
yeah beat it was Bill juice first and
then yeah Edward Scissorhands like those
movies but for him to come over
pee-wee's be like that's a pretty good
Derek regard is a pretty damn good film
you know and I fees oh maybe I would
have had to have been right because one
was Beetlejuice I'm not sure yeah it
makes it I mean by Chronicle instead of
put that together there myself another
actor turned director or was he really
acting Kevin Costner
Kevin cosplay don't remember the lineage
of Kevin Costner yeah yeah he's acting
he was acting I mean he stars in that
movie too and that's a movie that gets
pulled up whenever any whenever people
need an earmark for you know an avatar
type tale I feel like when avatar came
out I started hearing a lot more things
likened to its Dances with Wolves but
but that is a pretty great movie and and
it's weird I saw it I haven't seen in a
while but I saw it a lot growing up
because my mom and sister especially are
into like historical Western that was my
dad's movie wasn't he had like this
shiny and the movie was like [ __ ]
long as [ __ ] and but it was also on
laserdisc and he had like this special
collector's like five discs maybe 200
bucks
pleasure to snack that were already like
fifty dollars for one Dave's laser place
yeah yeah and then we also rotation
video yeah yeah now too bad oh I got one
that was heavily influential in both of
our lives
and that would be anchorman the
directorial debut of Adam McKay funny
talking about this now when their
company Gary Sanchez productions just
fell apart
yeah yeah yeah and they just had this
whole like we're still friends but we're
just not gonna work together on anything
anymore a big sound I just like whenever
when I heard that it's not some people
like have a warning sign about that of
not a warning sign but you know thinking
that maybe they had a falling out and
like now every time I said Will Ferrell
still doing [ __ ] like Holmes and watch
yeah exactly the case doing vice these
are like prestige so just makes sense
but yeah Adam II that that is the I mean
some people prefer like Talladega Nights
some people prefer Step Brothers to me
anchorman is the best I feel it my
favorite I feel like any animal Kate
join is probably a time and place thing
for you but yeah this one was like we
were all quoting it that's a sharpest
one I think so and and it does he
doesn't feel like improv movie but it
has all the the good parts of improv
movie in it yes it is unwieldy and loose
but it's still like rich but you can't
really quite tell when it's improvised
and when it's scripted it's like you're
not sure which one it is
yeah yeah yeah well it is kind of a long
movie so sharply edited yeah of all of
them it is the one that kind of is the
least too long yeah yeah
well it's funny when you when you watch
anchorman and and then you see what he's
done with things like the big short I
haven't seen Vice yet but when you see
what he's known things like the big
short you could see like the trinkets of
his transition there it wasn't like what
Todd Phillips was done with his life DP
roadtrip hell yeah because you watch
anchorman little Adam Kate Angelo I
going you watch anchorman which it seems
to have a real clear sense of what the
news station was like in the 70s yeah
you know like that was it's very as
funny as it isn't wacky as it is it
seemed to have a real in-depth
understanding about it it bothers to pay
and I think what the key to a lot of
their collaborations that they bother to
pay a lot of attention to the culture
that they're setting them in even though
they are super silly yeah that's
I think like it the movie doesn't get
accused of being sexist because it's
kind of commentating on the it's it's
that time stupid men were yeah that is
very that highlights the satire with
some hours to go with it just in case
you were any in any way confused and
then you know the other guys where he's
talking about like you know the Ponzi
schemes and stuffing even educating you
see they had a transitional period it
wasn't just what the hell the big short
you know and Will Ferrell helped
exactly exactly um there's a couple of
directors on here like I have back and
forth like J Richard Kelly for Donnie
Darko which is movies but it feels like
that's his only movie III I found him
when I was researching cuz it came to
mind and I was thinking about the
criteria for a great directorial debut
because the thing I was wondering too is
do you need to prove longevity to have a
great debut or is just the great first
movie that's it cuz yeah J Richard Kelly
has not made anything that people even
seem to regard as quality Donnie Darko
and his director's cut of Donnie Darko
is often less well received well I think
certain films like that you have a
harder time following up you know what I
mean it is so specific it's like the
weight and the pressure to follow up
because everyone kind of wants a Donnie
Darko to do what you did last time it's
kind of like what the thing Jordan Peele
had to face doing us is like people were
automatically gonna go who's a better
than get out and like we were aware that
that was gonna happen and sure enough
year so good out compares way it goes
and I just don't think he was able to
follow it up I met Richard I man hung
out with him once nothing that's not
like some fluff that actually legit hung
out with the guy
I was like oh you did that that's cool
and you know like tobe Hooper's kind of
a similar case I feel because Texas
Chainsaw and that's kind of what
everyone associates tobe Hooper for is
that first movie he made that is I feel
like that is tobe Hooper's undeniable
classic I mean there there are other
films that he's done that do have love
that do have followings that do have at
least name recognition but I would say
that you know especially with the amount
of bickering that goes on about who
directed poltergeist I feel like yeah
Texas Chainsaw is his biggest calling
card yeah I love that movie and funny I
didn't put this like I wrote him down
and then I deleted him and I thought you
wrote him down so I was like all right
we can mention him because despite my
personal opinion on this movie I don't
hate this movie I just I just I just I
get pretty and you know I'm I love me
some Mel you know but George but I
putting my personal feelings to the side
it's like objectively speaking it is
regarded as a monumental film for its
era and to kick-start a [ __ ]
fantastic franchise yeah Mad Max oh yeah
I mean I probably am George George
Miller Mad Max and I probably am with
you I mean like i prefer road warrior or
fury road to Mad Max for sure but I I
will say that yeah for its place in time
and for what it represents for what it
is you know especially being you know so
tangibly independent I do think it is at
least a yeah I really don't even watch
it like they're all kind of like I don't
know watch them in order I did and I was
like we could have just got like I
really felt like I just skip that back
we on a road warriors to Mad Max kind of
what Evil Dead 2 is the Evil Dead it's
like there's kind of that catch you back
up and then you're kind of in a
situation again but but you know how
like films were talking about with Evil
Dead
and El Mariachi and Night of the Living
Dead they all kind of have this charm of
its low-budget yeah they have this of
like working within the containment of
the restrictions such against
constraints this is pretty great yeah it
works and it adds this level of charm
Mad Max doesn't provide that for me
instead I'm kind of like this I'm really
bored it's it's kids is it considered a
great movie and I am aware that I am I
feel like I feel like it's one of those
movies that people get afraid to admit
they get bored through but you know what
I get bored watching yeah the flavor I
recall of it is it's harsh and
deliberate and yeah yeah you gotta be
patient with it whereas I feel like road
warriors yeah and this makes a good
segue to a movie that at least I can
talk about for a half second because he
just released another movie called Mandy
and that would be Panos cosmatos and I
really enjoyed beyond the black rainbow
a lot and that is a very striking and a
very impressive movie on a lot of levels
but I do feel that not not anywhere near
in the same way Mad Max 2 Road Warrior
but you know Brianna Black rainbows is
very deliberate you do have to be
patient with it it does have some of the
crazy sci-fi stuff that you know the
trailer shows you it's not quite as
watchable or or not watchable but it's
it's not quite as crazy and propulsive
as Mandy is but I think it is a like a
pretty astonishing aural visual
achievement you know especially for a
first-time director who I hadn't really
been aware of doing anything at the time
you know you see that moving you're like
wow somebody from a long time ago must
have made like yet 12 other movies like
this before this happens though alright
we got five minutes before we hit the 60
minute mark here so let's wrap this up
we've got two people left and both
movies I have not seen I have seen one
of them and that is This Is Spinal Tap
which is Rob Reiner do you haven't seen
Shawshank Redemption either no we both
have the greatest movie
greatest directorial debut every time
that is that is like this is spinal tap
I might get that for not seeing it but
Shawshank for Frank Darabont that's what
we're if I haven't seen it everyone's
like I will murder you if we're not
watching this movie because everyone's
allowed to cry during the Shawshank
Redemption i surprisingly haven't had
that room for me I don't know what I
don't know what happens in that movie
like I know the basic plot but I don't
know what goes on that and for Scott
both movies have not been room for me
surprisingly not be ad a cat kicking the
camera there if you happen to be
watching this late in the video
yeah neither of us has seen Shawshank
and and this is spinal tap as it is a he
both we're so weird this is a great
movie that deserves to be included and
this is spinal tap actor turned director
Rob Reider man
Lissie an actor yeah I guess that would
make sense I mean yes I've been an actor
right he's always acting not Carl Reiner
who's Carl Reiner the guy who talks like
this
I always knew Rob Reiner as an actor
first a director I feel like I mostly
know Rob Reiner is director okay like
he's been acting since 1961 all right
and then this is final maybe is 1984
maybe I just know Carl Reiner's face so
much more okay I just don't associate
emotions yeah he's in there oh wow I I
totally mix him up just now with Alan
Arkin anyway yeah that's all good
co-writer oceans low yeah yeah anyway
Rob Reiner actor turned director and and
this is fine but yes this is spinal tap
that's a I always thought I hope
freaking Rob Reiner directed that I
always think it's the guy who did for
your consideration Oh Christopher guess
I always think it's him well you because
it's so many of the people like they all
went on to be part of his troupe for the
most part at least a lot of them
guys like Harry Shearer and Michael
McKean and and Kirsten fer guessed
himself plays Nigel Tufnell writer
foreign but Rob Reiner he's even in the
movie as the documentarian you know kind
of breaking the fourth wall and stuff
and yeah I mean that definitely maybe
that's that that's yeah that makes a lot
of sense so like I guess Rob Reiner
decided he was kind of done with that
and then Christopher guess just picked
up the mantle and carried it on but like
people still reference spinal tap and it
is like a pretty personal reduces in
spinal tap yeah yeah yeah he's one of
the band members yes I know he's a Nigel
Tufnell but it does a great job at
sending up you know that particular rock
and roll culture as well as setting up
the mockumentary format you know that
crystal about it yeah oh there you go
that I didn't spend a whole Pratt's I
get that part of mine and to burn
director never before Christmas
definitely he did all right and then
just I just wanted to name a couple
movies and not talk quickly name though
we can I don't want to hit 60 minutes
sure if you're here and you want to
check out some bitchin cult movies that
we're also debuts repo man by Alex Cox
with Emilio Estevez is great The
Adventures of Buckaroo Banzai across the
8th dimension by WD richter also great
Hedwig and the Angry Inch John Cameron
Mitchell hell yeah wet hot American
summer David Wain hell yeah diner
Barry Levinson and airplane airplane or
sucker Abrams sucker is a directorial
debut and that kicked off hey rich genre
of parody boom all right guys well we
must have named at least 30 directors
for life I know for sure we did over 30
but minimum 30 directors who did we miss
if you made it this far in the video I'm
assuming this video got nobody yell at
us for gardens oh well there you go we
mentioned him forgot about that hey I
mean I've never seen Garden State that's
a great film is it I love that film I
love that the divisive indie movie
divisive I know some people who
vehemently hate it and some people who
really love it I think some people hate
it only because of how loved it was and
then they thought it was overrated but I
do love that movie
all right guys well he did crash was a
hysterical really of you Paul Green or
no Paul Paul's right there is that I
read written a lot was that his
directorial debut oh my goodness
let's find out director 13 credits Paul
Haggis know he directed another mine the
Chili Peppers movie yeah
Balthazar Getty okay so there was red
hot all right and I thought I had
another one what about Ron Howard okay
cast is gonna be like a song where we
just keep talking and it fades out very
like if you want the extended play
you're gonna have to buy another alright
guys well you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell and thanks Andrew Hayes for this
request only took a short amount of time
to film oh yeah Ron Howard's directorial
debut next day oh come on come on John
go go go
drug it 45 films in the first one was
Grand Theft Auto Oh based on the hit
video so the hit video game house yeah
he wrote it with a brother of his see
you guys